[Music]
next time on Iron Fist luck you give a
shit seriously are you idiots ever gonna
treat your superhero personas would
dignity pay we were gonna stop an evil
alien from destroying the world yeah but
we had a bar-hopping day we've been
planning for months and ain't nothin
gonna get in the way of that oh where
the hell is even tammer we told her
about our bender but she said she had
too much dignity and self-respect to
indulge in our childish behavior well at
least somebody had some sighs just
kidding she got blitzed on moonshine
I'll remember where we left her you
freaks
the world's on fire how about yours
that's the way I like it and I never get
bored oh no I mean
[Music]
what that happen a lot yeah why is this
like the 10th earth we've been through
on this show how could you let this
happen you know I miss it even though
we've left the world go to shit we've
been planning is better for a while a
big while when are you gonna learn the
great power comes great responsibility
Teddy Boy Fox learns that with great
franchises comes effort let me guess you
two just so fantastic four movies sadly
that's true Fantastic Four rise of the
sappers and that's the usual reaction
you know I have other pockets
[Applause]
[Music]
because 20th Century Fox loves to punish
you for liking comics that gave us a
sequel that really nobody was asking for
because well we saw the first one
Fantastic Four rise at the Silver Surfer
I guess tries to up the ante by giving
us a new character a wedding and that's
it not a whole lot was added and I guess
people recognize that as this was the
last for this particular Fantastic Four
series totaling this cast franchise to
just two flicks but to its credit the
others didn't attempt to make it that
far so I guess that's something does it
try the least out of the movies or does
it just appear to try the least well as
long as there's always a superhero
series that does very little
superheroing dude will always be here to
exploit it let's take a look at
Fantastic Four rise of the middle finger
I mean Silver Surfer we open on Planet
shit as it seems to be destroyed and a
glowing orb escapes its destruction man
DC Super Man reboots our King lazier the
credits fly by so quickly it's like
someone's tossing them out the garbage
disposal as even the description
captions are so embarrassed to be in
this movie they barely want to stand out
this whole movie has the attitude of we
made it we're sorry we're just gonna get
through it as quickly as possible the
beaming life flies around the earth
messing up the world's environments oh
my god he paused the movie we're trapped
here forever
blackouts frozen water snow in Egypt
this is an end-of-the-world ship right
here but the big story today is the
much-anticipated wedding a fantastic
couple Reed Richards and Susan storm
this Saturday that is word for goddamn
word what the news is reporting but the
big story today the much consistently
wedding a fantastic couple Reed Richards
and Susan storm this Saturday it's also
raining frogs in Detroit but what will
Susan's dress look like yeah if I had a
nickel every time I saw a headline like
that Neil deGrasse Tyson a genius or
famous genius I'm buying that paper as
the crowds continue to roll we see our
heroes at the airport sprinkling their
celebrity figuratively and sadly
literally wow this is better than I got
wave equates dandruff best birthday ever
but Susan is legitimately concerned
these end of the world reactions are
going to ruin her special day this is
gonna be the wedding you've always
dreamed of and I'm not gonna let
anything get in the way of that not even
the mysterious transformation of matter
at the subatomic level the world
explodes so she can have her happy
moment you know when they sing I'll stop
the world and melt with you it's not
scientifically sound advice it looks
like the Fantastic Four have their first
fantastic dilemma of fantastic
proportions the flight is overbought
it seems we're overbooked we do have
some seats available in coach though
how's the world looking again awesome
what are we focusing on that's my seat
sorry I was born ready for this let's
see our heroes excitingly steel luggage
space from unexpected saps
her medicines in that bag she'll have to
now check but at least you're using your
powers for good fantastic for their kind
of dip the news continues to discuss all
the crazy shit going on in the world
thank God our heroes still have the
focus where it needs to be I have a
fitting in half an hour
didn't even picked out the place
settings for the flowers new uniforms
just showed up there's no way we're
wearing that Johnny what do you have
against capitalism well nothing but
judging by that obvious Circuit City ad
and the fact that they went out of
business shortly after this film came
out what do you have against capitalism
Susan is so gung-ho about him being
focused on the wedding and nothing else
that he has to actually sneak his
research about saving the world without
her knowing keep it quiet but uh I've
cross-referenced and analyzed the global
disturbances but you know don't let any
of the other world scientists know but
Susan will throw a hissy fit they're
being caused by cosmic radiation not
unlike the kind which gave us our powers
that's really boring and I'm not just
saying that cuz I'm really freaking dumb
but screw those world destroying
disturbances the bachelor party man I
don't know anybody here
yeah whatever invited some of your
friends but you're gonna be don't have
any yeah maybe if we actually save
people instead of stealing overhead
compartments now we're awesome let's
party
Figg tries to hang out with bob teaching
miller ross we see how the Fantastic
Four is incredibly high-tech research
facility is heavily guarded that evening
and welcome to the fax to write you
can't use that Ellen tell the rob reiner
look-alike contest I'm gonna be late I
have to do my job like yes miss storm
will be with you shortly
hello yeah you'll have no other part in
this movie a couple hundred and special
effects down the tube we're here to see
dr. Richards I'm sorry he isn't here
right now is there anything I can help
you with yes you can take me to see dr.
Richards uh you know I'm a doctor to a
doctor of planning weddings which this
better not interrupt
she finds a lass to hurl Dancing with
some hotties much to her dismay his
talks will attract unless you need to do
jello shots off somebody's stomach no no
can I hear some place private a
completely abandoned kitchen in the
middle of a busy as hell nightclub I
mean seriously who eats can I do for you
as you may know they've been recent
unusual occurrences in all over the
world okay warning signs of movies gonna
be bad using the phrase as you know it's
a bad way to get out exposition because
if the person knows why are they saying
it as you may know they've been recent
unusual occurrences as you may know
there are many who consider the Miss
United States pageant outdated as you
know I conducted a raid on the Great
Library which most said didn't even
exist as you know those movies all blow
they say The Situation's a lot worse
than the public knows which already
sounded pretty bad and read can help by
building a sensor to track the cause of
the problem but he can't because you
know goodness really can't what you see
I'm getting married this Saturday I just
don't have the time gotta love this
guy's look like idiot you for real and
gotta love her look like yeah that's my
loving idiot who danced with two
strippers with his hands near their
crotches a second ago
forgive and forget that the world's
gonna die
it was nothing compared to what I did at
my bachelorette party Oh trust me we
know
you weren't invisible that night so dr.
doom from the last movie escaped because
apparently he had the same weak-ass
security of the Fantastic Four dead as
the big day arrives that's so half-assed
they openly say their Stan Lee cameo is
a Stan Lee cameo named Stan Lee yeah
nice try buddy Stan Lee my god they
destroyed his creation so much they
don't even recognize he's the creator
but even after stopping Reeve from
protecting humanity for her friggin days
she still isn't goddamn satisfied bitch
no Alicia it just doesn't feel right
could it be because we haven't saved
anyone we have been put in danger
ourselves and now by dodging our
responsibilities we're doing it again
all we know it's visit now all I have to
do is concentrate on the area
continuously for the next eight hours
but it looks like we did create this
sensor and was even finishing it on his
wedding day even as they say two craters
are heading to earth thing is telling
him to focus on more important things
we've already gotten reports of two more
craters okay the world to get married in
jackasses you're all jackasses you look
beautiful thank you
dad would be proud oh how touching
in that they're physically touching each
other outside that I don't feel shared
but don't worry
but sentimental casting of the priest
will win your heart over dearly beloved
we are gathered here today
wait I didn't even get a funny line
why'd you hire a comedian for this part
oh wait lip transmen Maui Maui buttons
is the badass crew and I'm gonna go bomb
a Big Bang Theory
but uh-oh things blind girlfriend seems
to be in danger
well they say your other senses are
heightened once one is gone and her
sense of stupidity not noticing a
gigantic loud blade early towards her is
certainly aunt Johnny chases after the
beam of light that caused the mayhem but
more importantly Susan is bummed about
her wedding day oh no you know this is a
side note but remember when she had to
cover her zit and she said this line now
all I have to do is concentrate on the
area continuously for the next eight
hours
so even when stopping a helicopter and
breaking down on her most important day
she still has that sit covered glad to
know where all the focus is going this
is the worst day I ever had knows it
knows that knows it I wonder how many
people died know that knows that knows
that knows it thanks man
my ADR is off they run to the men in
black coming the other direction
it looks like the beam of light is known
as the Silver Surfer who dragged Johnny
into space sadly not resulting in his
body exploding and surfer stalks with a
powerful entity your Herald summons you
another world awaits let it be done
quickly okay so that's Doug Jones as the
body of the Silver Surfer and that's
Laurence Fishburne as the voice of the
Silver Surfer it really doesn't work
Fishburne has a big booming voice that
should come out of a big booming body
the Jones is super tall and super skinny
and therefore sounds like this right on
time as always it's not the same deep
voices can't come out of thin bodies and
high voices can't come out of big bodies
but it's a Laurence Fishburne's voice
came out of this I talked to I taw a
puttytat I'd be a little distracted
wouldn't you mean well Johnny tells
everyone what he saw and it was flying
this like like a surfboard type thing I
know that sounds crazy so did you follow
the shiny mantle lollipop plan to the
rainbow Junction yeah isn't that crazy
corn pops man now let's go consult the
stretchy guy you were all jackasses
susan's okay that rebuilt the device
which seems surprisingly understanding
for her but she has more to say while
also making sure you don't sleep tonight
okay sorry please continue I didn't need
that urine in my body we will never have
normal lives as long as we do what we do
exactly what do we do again but
something happened when the surfer
touched Johnny that sounded worse than I
intended someone with powers touches him
they seemed the switch all right I'm
having strange physical thoughts I'd
never have for the Human Torch before
tsuya clothes why does this always
happen to me gotta love the unconvincing
way she said that line is if she knew
exactly why this always happens to her
why does this always happen to me now
why does thore always have his shirt off
this is weird they decide to play around
with him more as things switches powers
with torch oh my god come on you look
like one of the Smosh guys in a gritty
reboot of the Tigger movie actually Who
am I kidding that could be the next
Fantastic Four reboot hey hey it's me
I'm back Wow I felt human skin for the
first time in years the psychological
impact this is gonna have on me is
tremendous I meant nothing moving on you
and me are gonna be spending a whole lot
of time together pal that I can't
compete with the flame on joke you've
already made in your head so I'll just
continue all right just a reminder I'm
in this movie okay bye
so Susan sits around watching gossip
news about herself hey remember what you
used to do science
Henry tries to solve the problem what if
after this crisis is over we leave it
all behind I'll take a teaching position
somewhere and the two of us will live
our lives and raise a family like many
people maybe they have a point
all this superheroing is really
exhausting what's superheroing yes
you're right we've done so much for the
community just like the Fantastic Four
maybe we have earned calling it quits
you haven't done bullcrap you thinking
what I'm thinking what if mr. peanut has
a peanut allergy and we should give up
being the adequately impressive three
right
[Music]
it was a good run it was no run you
leave behind something beautiful
Hollywood marriages have lasted longer
they've stopped so many catastrophes
anything you stopped you started but if
we are to have our lives what lives must
make the sacrifice the adequately
impressive three
Oh is your probably let's hammer no oh
that's good hey it's over okay
[Applause]
so dr. tomb hunts down the surfer and
tries to make a deal with them together
we could be unstoppable
anything would be ours for the taking
I mean you with your world destroying
powers and me with my badass cloak all
the to know is at an end
[Music]
I'm sorry the surfers power seemed to
cure doom because that'll show him so
now he looks Leslie for Menace scum and
more like a wax model of Seth MacFarland
but even bigger problems are on the
horizon it seems every planet the surfer
visits it's always destroyed a week
later he's the ring video of apocalypses
gotta stick to the plan and work as it
so we're a team now that's news to me
what are you talking about you know what
I'm talking about
I should've told you all right I like
that's enough what the hell is wrong
with you people
I'm talking about you people filming
this scene have you ever been on a
helicopter why are you shooting it like
this you're shooting it like it's a back
and forth in a colorful funhouse and why
are you swimming in helicopters don't
zoom in you were all jackasses I find
out the next disturbance will be in
London so they tried to head over there
let's stop it
oh no does this mean the Fantastic Four
will actually have to do something
don't worry maybe Matt LeBlanc Invisible
Woman will save you with much more
impressive powers than I thought she had
holy shit she could do all this I feel
like there's a lot of scenarios where
encasing building sized objects and
walking on air could have been useful
and on top of that she still has that
zit covered it's only one day later
there's no Windex around she's clearly
still using energy on that so give him a
hand the Fantastic Four finally stops
something not caused by them though they
had time to focus more of these
anomalies and not the wedding they
probably go stopped it earlier but the
military doesn't see their good deeds as
good enough what the hell was that bring
it into my help general you bring in
more soldiers in weaponry you're gonna
put innocent people in danger that's our
job so the military asked dr. doom for
help because they don't realize how
stupid dangerous it is just to say ask
dr. doom for help his name is down the
world's at stake and we need to work
together to survive you know I just
figured out why I can't take dr. doom
seriously on top of that he always has a
sneer that looks like he's one step away
from making a childish insult don't
agree to this yeah how were the
residuals for King Arthur Lancelot I
knew that I wouldn't need you people
wouldn't you know quitting kept
America's dumb right give it your best
shot you're aware nip/tuck was overrated
without the dick at me you had dumb hair
somebody tries to figure out well the
surfer is gonna appear next let's see
how both Ben and super scientist I'm
sure maybe they can help in that or she
can just rub his neck and he gets blind
drunk bastard they do figure out where
he's gonna arrive next though and the
military again for no real reason decide
to treat them like assholes so let me
make it clear for you and your pack of
freaks here I'm the quarterback
you're on my team oh by the way thank
you for helping us find this thing
weirdo but I guess you never do football
in high school no you're right I stayed
in studying 15 years later I'm one of
the greatest minds of the 21st century
I'm engaged to the hottest girl on the
planet
gotta love fighting simplification by
simplifying his wife I'm engaged to the
hottest girl on the planet
oh she's also a director of genetic
Reese
save hundreds of lives and can walk out
for again nothing but being called the
hottest girl which she clearly didn't
like in the first film
that's the Invisible Girl girl that's
the most important thing that zit is
still covered up at least wait for her
to come across the surfer to prove how
useless she can be oh shit that's all I
had please give me a quick death why are
you destroying our planet I have no
choice there's always a choice if Chris
Evans can be in two Marvel property so
can you put you in one be ant-man's or
something but the surfer is attacked and
yeah that was kind of cool also kind of
cool oh there's the dumb I was looking
for not so tough now are you
you look like a cute who played your
video game so because it wouldn't be a
Doug Jones movie without him being naked
covered in makeup and looking in pained
here's all that stuff I just said really
be a little more however the Fantastic
Four aren't allowed to see the surfer
yes just to make the military look like
idiot assholes or something come on
they're besties with a guy named doom
they have to be smart so Susan sneaks in
to talk to him you said you weren't the
one trying to destroy our world then who
is
oh my god you're a Care Bear the surface
is he has to destroy worlds or else an
evil entity named Galactica's will
destroy his killing billions to save
millions I'm not a mathematician but
that seems pretty dumb why did you try
to protect me because you're the hottest
girl on the planet oh my god does anyone
take me seriously no actually I'm not
too far off
he says she reminds him of the woman he
loves and so he spared her yeah all your
education don't mean shit that's all you
got a familiar fine ass you're safe in
this universe what the hell is wrong
with you so the military decides to give
the all-powerful weapon to dr. doom
there is no way to rationalize that
sentence without sounding like a
complete dipshit but beyond all
comprehension dr. doom steals the
powerful weapon
[Music]
Oh oh no the mask what why does he have
that maybe he was to see if it looks any
better after all these years no still
looks dummy dumb he photoshopped any
resistance to death and escapes our
heroes tried to follow them but they're
stopped at the exit oh no it's that
woman Johnny shared one scene with and
she told him to piss off do I really
need to show her letting them go for no
reason no I told the hyuna's anyway
please well what can I do he said please
what the hell is well they track doom
down and tried to get the board away
from him before he huh they forgot to
say what his evil plan was I guess just
having the name doom was evil motivation
enough he's so evil he even uses the
exact same taunting motion twice you
know I've never been the giving type
come and get it Richard what is this
Doublemint commercial it looks like sue
sacrifices herself trying to save the
surfer I guess she had to because he's
been on that board so long he forgot how
to move his feet by the way you check
yes you were all jackasses but Johnny
has a plan to absorb everybody's power
to sneak up on doom it would take all of
us maybe just one of us we don't know
what it could do to you let's not make
this about me
see how you're making a joke like your
goddamn sister is dying you can't are
making it about you so he takes all
their abilities improves the power of
fantastic one it's clobberin time okay
top of everything else
there's just something inherently
hilarious about hearing a guy named dr.
doom in that ridiculous costume gasp
it's clobbering time just so freakin
funny hope with the other sounds that
didn't make the cut Alicia could do is
follow it up with a finally gets the
board away from doom but sadly it
doesn't look like sooo it's gonna make
it
[Music]
hottest girl in the world I guess this
inspires the surfer to stop Galactica's
really nothing else in all those worlds
he destroyed was as poetically powerful
as the star of good luck shot biting the
dust bow and he tries to set things
right tell her she was right we do
choice my choice is to get the hell out
of here I do see apes it's a nice planet
well lasted okay so this will be kind of
cool we're finally gonna see what
Galactica's looks like in the comic he's
a massive planet eating super giant even
give us a hint making the shadow look
like him heading towards Earth this is
gonna be pretty friggin cool so what do
we get giant space eNOS that looks like
it shit out the Lego layers
you sure collect a kiss didn't just send
his ass you sure everyone didn't just
send their ass surfer I guess sacrifices
himself kinda make you wonder why he
didn't save billions of lives before
doing that I mean I know he still gotta
kill himself but what kind of a dick
move and he also somehow gives life back
to sue what'd I miss
surfer magic I guess so after all of
that mayhem they try once again to get
married but if there's anything
masterpieces like The Legend of Zorro
Lethal Weapon 4 and flubber have taught
us it's that rushed weddings are
hilarion no they're not Venice is
sinking into the Adriatic let's get to
the end I now pronounce you man and wife
then you may kiss the bride
[Music]
who the hell are these people we invited
I recognize a couple but 80% I have no
clue but we still have time for throwing
the bouquet while Venice sinks
I guess Johnny sorry reflex he's an
asshole Oh
also had time to make our giant formal
Venice things again good to know
everyone's priorities are in the shitter
well I'm sorry to say but shitters full
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
tries less so I guess it offends less
it's got one or two neat things but
they're forgotten very quickly for the
lame storytelling and dialogue but that
was only rated PG so maybe the idea was
they wanted to be more of a kids bill
but I think even kids would find a lot
of this pretty boring because they don't
do much crime-fighting he didn't really
make me angry because it was coming off
of an already watched film but it
certainly didn't leave much of an impact
either it's just your run-of-the-mill
dumb no more no less and certainly
nothing fantastic but critic will the
adequately impressive three ever return
eliminated Malcolm it doesn't look like
Lee
but you never know if a certain clever
Fox and a certain clever Mouse can
figure things out
maybe we can tell maybe then we can have
once more a symbol something that
appeals to the best in each and every
one of us something good something
decent
[Music]
or not
[Applause]
[Music]
it's clobberin time
hey everyone Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out if you've been keeping
up with American news you know that
hurricane Florence has been making its
way through America just ruining several
several lives and that's why this week's
charity is the American Red Cross not
only do they specialize in occurrences
like this of helping people and going in
and making things better but if you
don't have money to donate you can also
donate blood they show you where you can
go how you can do it and all that stuff
uh so if this is something you really
want to help out with there's a lot of
people whose lives have either been
taken away or just ruined by this
terrible storm so please definitely
check out this wonderful organization
has been around for years and years they
do really phenomenal work please click
on the link and show your support
you